exposing the secret hacks to supercharge
your Urban Garden let's dive into the
top urban farming hacks for high yield
first up container gardening use deep
wide containers to give Roots room to
grow next companion planting peir plants
like tomatoes and basil they help each
other Thrive don't forget vertical
farming utilize walls and fences for
climbing plants saves space and boosts
yield water smart use drip irrigation
it's efficient and reduces Water waste
mulch mulch mulch it keeps soil moist
and weeds at Bay got pests try natural
Predators like ladybugs safe and
effective and finally keep planting
Cycles going rotate crops to keep soil
healthy and productive that's it happy
farming for more tips hit that like
button and subscribe